Speaker 1: Let's go next to oh, this is
new. Is this is this Miksa Mel from Kuwait.
We've never had a caller from Kuwait
before. Hello, yes, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: I am from Kuwait.
Speaker 1: Are you calling from Kuwait?
Speaker 3: Yes, I'm calling you are in Kuwait.
Speaker 1: Very good. Because sometimes we'll get
people who are like, oh, I'm from Saudi Arabia.
They're like, but I'm calling from Los Angeles.
You know, this is the real thing, it sounds like.
Speaker 3: No, I'm quite beautiful.
I just want to talk about the booster
vaccine, sure. I have lots of friends
who have taken the vaccine because in Kuwait
we have you can say. Like soft, mandatory,
like you can go to the Senate where you can go
to the restaurant unless you're vaccinated. Sure.
But now there is a booster shot and a lot of
my vaccinated friends are now even doubting the
vaccine. They say it's they feel like, you know,
they're messing with us, they're playing with us,
it's all about the money. So but I still believe
in the vaccine, I but I wonder. You know,
it's best not to promote the boozer because
that will spread, that will make, you know,
more harder for people to accept a vaccine.
Speaker 1: This is an interesting question.
I mean, listen, here's my thought on this. I think
we don't know how many shots we're going to need.
I think that's the truth. And so when we hear
about the third shot and then we hear from some
doctors who say the third shot is going to
be the last one, if anything, it'll be years
before we need another one. I think the truth is
we don't know that. And I think that it would be
better for everybody to just be up front and
say, listen, the things we know to be true today,
we didn't know six months ago and this
is evolving. And to say what we can say
today is that a third shot is going to boost your
antibodies for at least six months. And then,
you know what, in six months, depending on how
much change there is, how much mutation there is,
we may need more shots or we may need a
different shot tailored to the variance,
or maybe not. But what we know is today, the
best way to raise your antibody levels is to
get a third shot. I would appreciate that.
Rather than anybody saying the third one
will be the last one. I don't think we know that.
Speaker 3: OK, but my problem with it is that it
came very soon, like eight months after the second
shot. Yeah, I thought, like, if if it's a booster,
at least it would be like annually,
Speaker 1: which I agree with you.
I agree with you. Initially, the thought was
maybe once a year and now the data shows the
waning immunity. And so now they're saying six.
I agree it has changed. And I think that's why
I would appreciate communication that just says
we don't know the long picture. We just know you
should probably get one after eight months or six
months or whatever they say. I would be fine with
them saying we just don't know.
Speaker 3: OK, but I think
in Kuwait, because we do have, like very strict
laws, you know, people will take, you know,
the vaccine. Yeah. Whether they like it or not
Speaker 1: mean is it widely available there,
makes them ill. Is it is it easily anybody
who wants one can get one in Kuwait.
Speaker 3: At first it wasn't
very easy, but now it's very easy.
Speaker 1: OK, got it. So it's not unreasonable
to require it because anybody can get it.
Yes, anybody can get it makes sense,
Speaker 3: but you have to,
but you have to register, it's not like
in the United States where you just
can't go to any store and take it. Now you have
to register and wait in line, something like that.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. OK,
very good to you. All right. Thanks so much.
Appreciate the call. First caller ever from
Kuwait. Very, very exciting. Appreciate it.
Let's go next to Noah from Los
Angeles. Noah. You're on the air.
Noah from Los Angeles, you're on the air.
This may be our first drop, Noah
from Los Angeles, last chance.
Hello. Hello. I can hear you now.
Speaker 3: Oh, you can. Good, thank you. Pleasure.
This is my first time ever calling in. All right,
so let's try and figure out how to use this court.
Nice disclaimer. I'm a right leader. OK.
But I like listening to your show. My question
is for you, what do you say to somebody
who says that like a 15 dollar minimum
wage is kind of like a corporatist
favoring policy because the bigger corporations
can afford to pay the 15 dollar minimum wage?
Speaker 1: I think that that's first we have to
ask whether that's even true, and I think it's far
more complicated than that. You know, businesses
that are based around services versus businesses
that are based around products will be differently
able to afford the 15 dollar minimum wage. I think
it's extremely location dependent, as I've said
before. I mean, here's the problem. I have no with
people who just come up with a talking point
and then they just repeat it every time they
get an opportunity and see how people react.
Rarely does the talking point or the rebuttal
really, really account for the complexity
of the situation. So it's like, yeah, I,
I kind of get what you're saying. Businesses
with more money can better dampen the impacts
of changes to their costs. OK, sure. That that has
this general appeal and intuitive intuitiveness,
but reality is far more complicated. So I would
say to that person, there's a lot more to the
question of the minimum wage than simply that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, the person I mean,
there's a smaller you tube, but the person who
is saying that they basically did say what you
just said like this doesn't mean that, like,
we need to throw it out. They're just saying,
like, that's something to think about.
Speaker 1: Right. I completely agree with you.
All right, well, thank you very much. My
pleasure. There is no other right leaner
from Los Angeles that is going
to do it for calls today.
We will take calls again. And I look
forward to hearing from you next time.